harley quinn is practically the
anti-heroic queen of the dc universe but
the one place you aren't going to find
her is zack snyder's justice league
even at 4 hours in length the film
apparently didn't have room for margot
robbie's harley amongst the story of the
greatest heroes on earth battling
steppenwolf from remaking earth on
apocalypse's image the outcome of the
justice league snyder cuts is similar to
that of the theatrical version that was
released in 2017
however it's a lot clearer in the
director's cut that darkseid is coming
and we're left with one final scene in
which batman and his crew of misfits
wander around the post-apocalyptic
hellscape batman has a vision of
it's here in the premonition of the
nightmare reality where batman has a
brief conversation with the joker
however joker's presence in the snyder
cut does lead to some questions
the most immediately pressing of which
regards harley quinn if joker's around
then wears his beloved partner in crime
in a key piece of dialogue in zack
snyder's justice league harley's fate is
revealed
isn't that right
batman in the film batman has another
vision of the nightmare reality that
seems to be what's destined to happen
when darkseid comes to earth this
sequence shows batman agreeing to a
truce with the clown prince of crime
however while they don't go at each
other's throats in the moment it's clear
there's still a lot of animosity between
the two especially when joker brings up
the dark knight's greatest failing
allowing his sidekick robin to die
batman throws the statement back at his
arch-nemesis by mentioning how harley
quinn died in his arms
he also tells joker that harley made him
promise that when he finally killed her
ex-boyfriend he had to do
it slowly batman tells joker she begged
me with her last breath that when i
killed you
and make no mistake i will kill you i do
it slow and i'm gonna honor that promise
it's an intense moment and the magnitude
isn't lost on joker who quivers after
the threat
no more information is given outside of
that such as what caused harley quinn to
die but one thing is abundantly clear
she and joker definitely probably didn't
make up before her death while it seems
unlikely at this point that justice
league 2 will come to fruition
especially with snyder at the helm we at
least know that harley probably won't
have a role within the nightmare
timeline if the project does happen
someday
that wasn't me so is there a chance we
could actually see this heartbreaking
death scene come up in a future dc eu
film that isn't a justice league sequel
don't hold your breath
outside of a role in the upcoming flash
movie it's looking more and more
unlikely that affleck will be the
mainline dark knight going forward
especially given the fact that batman's
getting a solo movie that stars robert
pattinson as a younger bruce wayne and
doesn't seem to have anything to do with
the snyder films despite all of the
shaky continuity within the dc eu
robbie's harley quinn appears as though
she'll continue to be a force in the
franchise going ahead
in just a few months she'll appear in
the suicide squad which debuts in
theaters and on hbo max on august 6th
2021
beyond that upcoming movie it's unclear
what harley quinn's cinematic future
could entail
the suicide squad writer director james
gunn teased on instagram a while back
that he and robbie discussed working
together in the future one would assume
if the suicide squad is well received a
follow-up would be in the cards with
robbie returning to the cast
there's also the possibility of a sequel
to birds of prey as well as a solo
harley quinn movie
there's a lot of room for growth with
the anti-heroine and dc probably isn't
going to kill her off anytime
soon just to make good on a scene that
exists only in a director's cut version
of a film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book heroes and
villains are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one